creepiness finally comes back to haunt
Uncle Joe Biden president Trump polls
closing the border and Democrats
demonstrate their lack of knowledge I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
I've been saying for weeks President
Biden Vice President Biden that his for
his best day will be his first day and
then his worst day will be every day
after that I will provide you the
evidence of this contention in just one
second but first in 2008 the US national
debt was 10 trillion dollars today that
it is nearly 22 trillion dollars it is
rising like a hockey stick if you don't
think we are sitting on a house of cards
who are living with their head in the
sand but since you listen to my podcast
you're clearly smarter than the average
bear so what is your plan can you afford
another hit to your retirement like the
last downturn when the S&P dropped 50%
hedge against inflation hedge against
uncertainty and instability with
precious metals gold is a safe haven
against uncertainty my savings plan is
diversified and yours should be to at
least a little bit the company I trust
with precious metal purchases is Birch
gold group and right now thanks to a
little-known IRS tax law you can even
move that IRA or eligible 401k into an
IRA backed by physical gold and silver
perfect for people who want to protect
their hard-earned retirement savings
from any future geopolitical uncertainty
if you look back historically when the
bottom falls out of everything else gold
does tend to safeguard savings Birch
gold group has thousands of satisfied
customers countless five-star reviews an
A+ rating with the Better Business
Bureau contact Birch gold get a free
information kit on physical precious
metals today see if diversifying into
gold and silver makes sense for you you
can go check them out right now at
birchgold.com slash Ben or text Ben to
47 47 47 get that no-cost no-obligation
kit text Ben to 47 47 47 again that's
text my name Benton to 47 47 47 for more
information alrighty so Vice President
Joe Biden if you look at the polls right
now the early primary polls he's leading
he's got close to 30 percent in most of
these polls Bernie Sanders trails him or
but by up to 10 points sometimes it's a
little bit closer but Joe Biden has won
kind of serious problem that is now
cropped up over the last three days yeah
that right there's a problem so
according to one accuser there's an
accuser who has come forward and
suggested that she was in
Oh Prix Utley touched and kissed by Joe
Biden now that sounds a little bit worse
than it is here is what she actually has
to say her name is Lucy Flores and we
have to take her account with a slight
grain of salt in the sense that she was
seen attending a bado rally within the
last week or two but she says this in
2014 I was the 35 year old Democratic
nominee for lieutenant governor of
Nevada this is according to New York
Magazine the landscape wasn't looking
good for my party that year there were
no high profile national races to help
boost turnout and after the top
candidate bowed out of the governor's
race none of the above ended up winning
the Democratic primary so in my campaign
heard from VP Joe Biden's office that he
was looking to help me and other
Democrats in the state I was grateful
and flattered his team offered to bring
him to a campaign rally in an effort to
help boost voter turnout we set the date
for November 1st just three days before
Election Day in a state as large but
sparsely populated as Nevada writes Lucy
Flores it takes non-stop travel to
connect with all of its residents I
sprayed some dry shampoo in my hair
raced off to Reno Airport and flew back
to Las Vegas the event proceeded as most
political events do coordinated chaos
with random problems that no one can
predict and then Joe Biden showed up she
said I found my way to the holding room
for the speakers where everyone was
chatting taking photos and getting ready
to speak to the hundreds of voters in
the audience just before the speeches we
were ushered to the side of the stage
where we were lined up by order of an
introduction as I was taking deep
breaths and preparing myself to make my
case to the crowd I felt two hands on my
shoulders I froze why is the Vice
President of the United States touching
me I felt him get closer to me from
behind he leaned further and inhaled my
hair I was mortified I thought to myself
I didn't wash my hair today and the Vice
President of the United States is
smelling it and also what in the actual
eff why is the Vice President of the
United States smelling my hair he
proceeded to plant a big slow kiss on
the back of my head my brain couldn't
process what was happening I was
embarrassed I was shocked I was confused
there's a Spanish saying tegami tiara it
means earth swallow me whole I couldn't
move and I couldn't say anything I
wanted nothing more than Biden to get
away from me my name was called and I
was never happier to get on stage in
front of an audience she says I'd never
experienced anything so blatantly
inappropriate and unnerving before Biden
was the second most powerful man in the
country and arguably one of most
powerful men in the world who's there to
promote me is the right person for the
lieutenant-governor job instead he made
me feel uneasy
gross and confused the vp of the united
states had just touched me in an
intimate way reserved for close friends
family or romantic partners and I felt
powerless to do anything about it so why
exactly didn't she say anything for
years well she says she told a few on
her staff what happened immediately she
said she didn't plan on telling anybody
else and I didn't have the language or
the outlet to talk about what happened
well I mean she was the nominee for
lieutenant governor so that's probably
not true just who do you tell what do
you say is it enough of a transgression
if a man touches and kisses you without
consent
but doesn't rise to the level of what
most people consider sexual assault I
did what most women do and moved on with
my life and work time passed and
pictures started the surface of VP Biden
getting uncomfortably close with women
and young girls by nuzzling the neck of
the defense Secretary's wife Biden
kissing a senator's wife on the lips
Biden whispering in woman's years Biden
snuggling female constituents I saw
obvious discomfort in the women's faces
and Biden I'm sure never thought twice
about how it made them feel I knew I
couldn't say anything publicly about
what those pictures surfaced for me my
anger and my resentment grew had I never
seen those pictures I may have been able
to give Biden the benefit of the doubt
and then she continues and talks about
why exactly she didn't do anything she
says but the problem now is it shows a
lack of empathy for the women and young
girl whose space he is invading and
ignores the power imbalance that exists
between Biden and the women he chooses
to get cozy with she says when I spoke
to a male friend who's also a political
operative in Biden's orbit he did what
no one else had and made me question
myself and wonder if I was doing the
right thing he reminded me that Biden
has significant resources and argued
points that made me question my memory
even though I've replayed that scene in
my mind a thousand times he reminded me
that my credibility would be attacked
and that I should be prepared for the
type of back-and-forth that could occur
I'm not suggesting the Biden broke any
laws but the transgressions that society
deems minor
or doesn't even see his transgressions
often feel considerable to the person on
the receiving end that imbalance of
power and attention is the whole point
and the whole problem okay so here is
Biden's accuser suggesting that what she
really wants is just for him to
acknowledge his wrong the invasion of
her personal space now of course she
knows that if he acknowledges his wrong
then he's basically toast because if you
acknowledge wrong in this witch-hunt
environment then you are finished now
we'll discuss whether Joe Biden is in
fact a creeper or whether he just kind
of acts like a creeper in just a second
but here's lucy Flores on CNN with Jake
Tapper what are you looking for
from the vice president here Vice
President Biden are you looking for an
apology are you looking for him to
change his behavior what what's the
endgame here what do you want absolutely
I would yes of course I want him to
change his behavior and I want him to
acknowledge that it was wrong and I want
this to be a bigger discussion about how
there is no accountability structure
within our political space we are not
protected in politics okay so it is true
that there are situations in which men
have in public harassed women right this
would be the story of Al Franken
multiple women alleging that Al Franken
groped their behinds while he was taking
pictures with them but let's be straight
about this the only actual accusation of
truly inappropriate conduct here or at
least conduct that made someone feel bad
is Lucy Flores right that's the real
case now the reason this is resonating
is of course because there are plenty of
pictures of Joe Biden acting creepy with
women I mean here's just a little bit of
Joe Biden acting creepy with women and
young girls so you can see him he's kind
of nuzzling this this little girl who
happens to be the daughter of a sitting
senator and she's kind of pulling away
from him because he's getting too close
and he gives her a kiss on the head and
hears him with another little girl and
he kind of leans forward and whispers
into her ear puts both his hands on her
shoulders another senator's daughter
he's talking to another another woman
there and kind of cozy there he is
getting cozy with a very little girl who
of course is not his not his grandkid
and Harry is kind of stroking the face
of a very small girl who doesn't look
supremely comfortable with the whole
thing and there he is kind of putting
his hands through the little girl's hair
so he does this all the time I mean he's
gay like stroking faces and then of
course the most famous one is him
holding the shoulders and then leaning
in and sort of whispering to the wife of
ash Carter on the day that her husband
was sworn in as defense secretary and of
course a lot of people pointed out that
was weird but Stephanie Carter who is
that wife and who has been featured in
virtually all of these photos she says
no
wasn't a thing so she has a piece today
called the me2 story that wasn't me
she says it happened to again two weeks
ago I was at an industry conference
compromised of my female peers what
would be the last time there as I had
announced my intent to start my own
company when a friend ran up to me
joyously stating she'd seen me I assumed
she was referring to a recent piece in
an industry newsletter about my
retirement for my firm and transition to
entrepreneurship but she quickly let me
know it was again that picture which
Jimmy Fallon had shown the night before
last night I received a text from a
friend letting me know that picture was
once again all over Twitter in
connections hulusi Flores his personal
accounts of a 2014 encounter with Joe
Biden let me state upfront that I don't
know her but I absolutely support her
right to speak her truth and she should
be like all women believed but her story
is not mine
the Joe Biden in my picture is a close
friend helping someone get through a big
day for which I will always be grateful
so as sole owner of my story at his high
time I reclaim it from strangers Twitter
the pundits and late-night host and she
talked about how the day that her
husband was being sworn in as Secretary
of Defense she was very nervous there
was a point at which she slipped and
then came the time that she was standing
there while her husband was was being
sworn in she says after the swearing in
as Ashe was giving remarks he leaned in
this would be Biden to tell me thank you
for letting him do this and kept his
hands on my shoulder as a means of
offering support but a still shot taken
from a video misleadingly extracted from
what was a longer moment between close
friends sent out in a cenar key tweet
came to be the lasting image of that day
as I arrived home to my apartment that
night I was starting to get a sense from
incoming texts that that picture was
picking up steam says Stephanie Carter -
Carter's wife I got on the elevator it
must have been - lost in thought -
notice someone next to me as I got off
the elevator
the young woman started walking down the
hall and began to feel her footsteps to
pick up clothes - - I reached my door I
turned around to find her practically on
top of me when I confronted her she said
she was a reporter from the New York
Post and today I have a comments about
that picture I quickly went inside and
locked the door she didn't stop the next
day or the day after that she talks
about how for years now people have been
basically using this as proof that Biden
doesn't know how to respect women he
says I thought it would all blow over
this is Stephanie Carter I thought it
would all blow over if I didn't dignify
it with the response but clearly that
was wishful thinking I won't pretend
this will be the last of that picture
but it will be the last of other people
speaking for me so Stephanie Carter has
a very different experience than Lucy
Flora she says no you know Biden is
handsy but
and he's not even handsy is what she's
saying she's saying that we are just
close friends and Biden himself has put
out a statement on all of this we'll get
to that in just one second first let's
talk about that hair atop your head
losing your hair stinks you don't
realize how much you care about it until
you start losing it which is why you
should be using keeps the easiest and
most affordable way to keep the hair
that you have these FDA approved
products used to cost so much but now
thanks to keeps they're finally
inexpensive and easy to get for five
minutes now just a buck a day you're
never gonna have to worry about hair
loss again getting started with keeps is
actually really easy sign up takes less
than five minutes you just answer a few
questions and you snap some photos of
your hair and then a licensed physician
will review your information online and
recommend the right treatment for you
it's trip direct to your door every
three months keeps offers generic
versions of the only to FDA pre hair
loss products out there some of you have
probably tried them before you've
probably never gotten them for this
price keeps it's only 10 bucks to 35
bucks a month plus now you can get your
first month for free it's a heck of a
deal forgetting to keep your hair to
receive your first month of treatment
for free go to keeps calm / Bend that is
ke EPS calm / but here's the thing once
you start losing all of your hair it's
kind of too late if all your hair is
gone nothing in the world can regrow it
but there are drugs on the market they
can prevent you from losing your hair
and that's why you should reach out to
keeps they'll give you a free month of
treatment and keeps calm / Ben that's
keeps calm / Ben keeps hair today hair
tomorrow go check them out right now
okay so joe biden is responding to this
controversy with a statement he says in
my many years on the campaign trail and
in public life I've offered countless
handshakes hugs expressions of affection
support and comfort Biden said and not
once never did I believe I acted
inappropriately if it has suggested I
did so I will listen respectfully but it
was never my intention he said I may not
recall these moments the same way I may
be surprised at what I hear but we have
arrived at an important time when women
feel they can and should relate their
experiences and men should pay attention
and I will I will also remain the
strongest advocate I can be for the
rights of women and then he talks about
how his politics should basically excuse
any behavior that women have perceived
as wrong so there's Biden basically
understanding that he is a bind he's in
a bind now that he can't get out of
because we live in a culture where a
woman's accusation of wrongdoing is
tantamount to proof that the wrongdoing
occurred remember these are the same
Democrats who said that Christine Blasi
Ford when it came to Brett Kavanaugh was
innately telling the truth that all of
the other accounts were to be believed
well until it turned out the day fell
apart or were to be ignored and then
they said the Brett Kavanaugh could not
sit on the Supreme Court because of all
of that we live in a time when if a
woman says that for a subjective reason
she feels as though she was abused in
some way that the man is to blame for
the subjective feeling of abuse now I
will say that as a personal practitioner
of the I don't get close to people
without their consent thing I've always
found Joe Biden's behavior creepy I've
never been a big fan of this but there
are people out there who are just
huggers there are people out there who
don't understand the limits of personal
space these are the people who are the
clothes stalkers the people who had
parties feel like it's good to shake
your hand and then hold your hand too
long there are people who are like this
that doesn't mean that they are
attempting to harass you and intent does
matter here at least somewhat because
there's a difference between a sexual
assault which presumably requires a
certain level of intent and I held your
hand too long and it was awkward for you
but I didn't even know what the hell was
going on ignorance in fact is somewhat
of a defense at least to the idea that
you are a creepy person who deserves to
be treated as some sort of moral sinner
in this way so this is not a full
defense of Joe Biden but it is true that
Joe Biden's behavior has never really
been complained about by anybody except
for this one particular woman now if the
spate of women come out and they say
that he's been randomly coming up to me
at parties and then kissing me on the
back of the head I mean look that's
weird behavior it's just weird
odd behavior and again if somebody came
to my wife and put their hands on her
shoulders and kissed her on the back of
the head the first time I met her that
person may end up knocked to the ground
that's that's not appropriate behavior
but with that said Joe Biden people get
accustomed to being treated in a certain
way and Joe Biden apparently has gotten
accustomed to being able to get away
with this kind of behavior to the point
where I'm not sure he even notices it
now I will say that the media coverage
of this is very different because Joe
Biden is a Democratic frontrunner than
it would be were he not I will tell you
about in Washington Post headline in
just a second so the Washington Post's
headline today in the politics section
quote Joe Biden's affectionate physical
style with women comes under scrutiny
okay the descriptors there instead of
just Joe Biden's physical style with
women comes under scrutiny affectionate
physical style with women oh that's what
it is he's just that's all he is
the The Washington Post has this
affectionate and sometimes intimate
physical style is one of the former vice
president's trademarks a defining
feature of the warm and upbeat persona
he is built during more than four
decades in the national spotlight oh
that's the defining feature of the warm
and upbeat persona is what it is it's
not just him randomly getting too close
to people because he doesn't understand
personal boundaries but the
appropriateness a Biden's physical
behavior toward women is now being
questioned after a female Democratic
politician and a viral internet piece
describing an alleged 2014 encounter
they left her offended and uncomfortable
now here's where the trouble comes in it
is difficult to determine whether people
are truly outraged or whether there is
just political hay being made while the
Sun shines and I'll demonstrate so
Bernie Sanders who is in a position to
hurt Biden here if you were to come out
against Biden says listen I'm not sure
that one complaint really discredits
Biden here's Bernie Sanders on Face the
Nation suggesting that well this woman
should be listened to is that really an
indicator that Joe Biden is a serious is
a serial sexual assault her in some way
she says she's coming for us now because
she thinks that's disqualifying
for Joe Biden do you think it's
disqualifying
well I think that's a decision for the
vice president to make I'm not sure that
one incident alone disqualifies anybody
but her point is absolutely right this
is an issue not just the Democrats or
Republicans the entire country has got
to take seriously it is not acceptable
that when a woman goes to work or is in
any kind of environment that she feels
anything less than comfortable and safe
okay now it's hilarious again is that
the same Democrats who complain about
this sort of stuff and say that women
need to be feeling safe at the office
something with which I agree will rip
out Mike Pence for saying that he
doesn't want to meet alone with women
for fear of being of being accused of
inappropriate behavior dick Durbin says
the same thing he says listen one
allegation here is not disqualifying for
Joe Biden this is the senator from
Illinois Joe Biden is a friend and a
seasoned veteran when it comes to
political campaigns I know nothing about
the allegations that I also read this
morning as well I think all of us should
take such allegations seriously and with
respect I took the Joe Biden statement
to say just that exactly so yes I think
he's ready if that's his decision to
move forward in this press
campaign we have a spirited field of 15
or 16 cases disqualify us the spectrum
and the Democratic Party and its values
certainly one allegation is not
disqualifying but it should be taken
seriously okay so I actually think that
dick Durbin's point here is actually
pretty well taken especially because as
it turns out Luci Flores is not exactly
a politically uncommitted person right
Lucy Flores is a fan apparently of bado
O'Rourke and she is it is odd the timing
of all of this she actually was at a
rally for bata O'Rourke on Saturday so
that it's hard to take all of this
without at least a grain of salt even if
I think the Joe Biden is handsy with
with people he should not be handsy with
he honestly how many guys do you know
who are like this I know people who are
like this older people particularly who
are like this who my wife deals with
that on a regular basis as a doctor
she's constantly going into rooms with
you know usually there's a third person
there and sometimes there are older
people there older men particularly who
will act inappropriately and it's like
okay well my wife sort of just gets over
it which is not a suggestion that the
men's behavior is okay but it's possible
that Joe Biden doesn't know what he's
doing that's possible Joe Biden does
know what he's doing I don't know but I
will say that I'm not going to take at
face value accusations from people like
Elizabeth Warren who are in a race with
Joe Biden and Elizabeth Warren I don't
remember caring very deeply about Bill
Clinton engaging in behavior
significantly worse than any of this so
all I'm saying is skepticism of
politicians is warranted here senator
Elizabeth Warren who's flailing around
right now I mean she is just flailing
she lost her campaign finance director
she's unable to raise money she's
falling apart at the seams but she does
have one line of attack on Joe Biden and
that is that she believes this accuser
last night I believe Lucy Florence and
Joe Biden needs to have an answer
should he not run as a result okay so
Amy clobber char saying the same sort of
thing she of the she of the making her
aides clean the combs with which she
eats her salad here is Amy clapper tried
the Center for Minnesota also running
and also doing the same routine he's
also one who has said in situations like
this that the default is to believe the
woman to believe the accuser
do you believe Lucy Flores I have no
reason not to believe her Jonathan and I
think we know from campaigns and from
politics that people raise issues and
they have to address them and that's
what he will have to do with the voters
if he gets into the race okay so the
only point I'm making here is that I
don't know the motivations of the people
who are attacking Joe Biden here again I
think on an objective level on an
objective level his behavior with people
who are not his wife or child's it's
weird to me it's obviously weird to me
but there's only one complaint so far
and that complaint comes from somebody
who happens to be politically motivated
against Biden and had nothing to say for
five years about this particular
incident so that makes me a little
skeptical now it is also possible that
the female senator is in the race maybe
some of them have experienced stuff like
this and so they have a stronger belief
system on this than the men maybe there
is an actual sex gap here and men don't
understand what women are going through
and so they're more likely to brush off
accusations like the one against Biden
but it's hard for me to take at face
value complaints from people who are in
direct competition with Senator or with
Vice President Biden when it comes to
all of this so I will take this more as
yet another line of attack against Joe
Biden rather than as the Democratic
Party suddenly discovering the job iDEN
is weird with women because you've been
weird with women for years again we've
seen this sort of stuff going on for
legitimately it's been a meme on the
right for half a decade that Joe Biden
does this sort of stuff I mean they're
pictures of him at campaign stops with
women on his lap Joe Biden's been doing
this for a long time no complaints so
kind of hard to take seriously the
Democratic Party's sudden observation
that Joe Biden is actually creepy with
women as opposed to they're just trying
to knock him out of these primaries
they're just trying to knock him out of
these
all righty so in just a second we'll get
to Democrats who are continuing to flail
around for some answers to their own
policies first let's talk about how you
can make your company better hiring is
challenging there's one place you can go
or hiring is simple fast and smart it's
a place where growing businesses connect
to qualified candidates that place is
zip recruiter comm slash daily wire zip
recruiter sends your jobs to over 100 of
the web's leading job boards but they
don't stop there with their powerful
matching technology zip recruiter scans
thousands of resumes to find people with
the right experience and then invites
them to apply to your job as
applications come in zip recruiter
analyzes each one and spotlights the top
candidates so you never miss a great
match zip recruiter is so effective that
80% of employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the very first
day right now my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address zip recruiter comm slash daily
wire that zip recruiter comm slash Dai
ly WI re zip recruiter Tom slash daily y
reciprocally is indeed the smartest way
to hire again they're so effective that
80% of employers who post on zip
recruiter data quality candidate through
the site within the very first day
there's a reason we use zip recruiter
ourselves here at daily wear to run our
business at zip recruiter comm slash
daily wired to try it for free
zip recruiter comm slash daily wire and
meanwhile the Democrats continue to
demonstrate that they really don't know
a lot of things and leading the charge
is of course the inimitable Alexandre
Ocasio Cortez over the weekend she
suggested that she wants people to
debate her which is odd since when I
actually challenged her to a bait she
accused me of catcalling so does that
but she had herself a very weird episode
of Chris Hayes all in with Chris Hayes
on MSNBC in which she said a bunch of
things that make no sense and yet she
continues to be a hail that some sort of
thought leader for the Democratic Party
which was pretty amazing since she
doesn't have lots of thoughts but she
doubled down on the notion that we are
at risk from cow farts she doubled down
on her green new deal here is a OSI
thought leader of the Democratic Party
continuing to push this nonsense
innovate on our technology you know
obviously like anna stafford you know
police the document to talk about cow
flatulence but which is an issue i just
want to say but it literally is
as an issue when it comes to
contributing to methane but that doesn't
mean you end cows it means that we need
what it means is that we need to
innovate and change our grain are our
cow brain from which you know they feed
in these troughs that we need to really
take a look at regenerative agriculture
like these are our solutions
what is regenerative agriculture maybe
maybe she's just too smart for me I
don't know what the hell she's talking
about when she says we have to feed them
different grains like what pepto-bismol
or what and it literally says in her
green New Deal frequently asked
questions that we have to end cows so
I'm glad that she's running away from
that at least she realized that was a
bad idea
then she blamed her staff for the
rollout of the green New Deal so yeah
that was my foot that wasn't my fault
that was my staffs fault it was because
they rolled out a draft version of the
frequently asked questions now this is
just a lie what you're about to hear
because they rolled out this draft
supposedly online there was no final
draft that came after that now normally
there have been cases at Daily wire or
somebody accidentally approves a draft
of an article you know what we do we
then corrupt correct and update the
article as soon as possible meaning like
within the hour we're now like two
months later and she still has not
released a full frequently asked
question so that was not a draft that
was her final version and she only
realized was a bad idea after it was
released to the public nonetheless here
she is blaming her staff for the rollout
queue it had some things that people
thought were ridiculous and radical like
anyone that was unable or unwilling to
work when we guaranteed a job
the FAQ was withdrawn and said it was
preliminary a draft there was a lot of
fight about that like you do you think
you guys rolled it out the right way did
you bring it back any on yourself what I
will say is that there I definitely had
a staffer that had a very bad day at
work and did release a working draft
early so I get that that's what they're
seizing on but really what we need to do
is have a serious conversation so sick
of her calling for a serious
conversation when she won't have one
with any one of merit Chris Hayes just
throws her softball after softball and
she's called let's have a serious
conversation really what's your serious
conversation is there serious
conversation that everybody who
criticizes you is in the pay of
nefarious right-wing forces is is your
serious conversation that everybody who
criticized
as you is lately a sexist or a bigot is
that your serious conversation AOC
maybe people who criticize you criticize
you because you don't know things
because you say dumb crap on a regular
basis
eg same interview she explains that
Congress passed an amendment to the
Constitution to prevent FDR from being
reelected let me explain why this is
DOMA in one second when our party was
boldest the time of the new New Deal the
Great Society the Civil Rights Act and
so on we had and carried super
majorities in the house in the Senate we
carried the presidency they had to amend
the Constitution of the United States to
make sure Roosevelt did not get
reelected and we you know there were so
many extraordinary things that were
happening in that time that were uniting
working people uh no no that is just not
true so it is true that Democrats are
winning enormous majorities in the
middle of the Great Depression because
people were blaming Herbert Hoover and
the Republicans for all that it is also
true that Congress was in fact regained
by Republicans at some point during this
period but it is also true what is she
wait hold up just hold up for one second
is she claiming that the 22nd amendment
to the Constitution was passed to
prevent FDR from winning another
election is that is that the actual is
that the actual contention because it
was actually ratified the completed
ratification happened in 1951 that was
the last state to ratify that was
Alabama which ratified in 1951 FDR died
in 1944 they started the initiation of
this process after his death so how did
they pass a constitutional amendment who
stopped him from serving after he was
dead what okay but it's okay she knows
things guys she knows things the beauty
of being a Democrat is that no matter
how radical you are there are always
members of the media like chris hayes to
defend you you want to see a great
example of the media not asking
eminently obvious follow-up question so
Bernie Sanders was asked over the
weekend accidentally on Face the Nation
in actual question so he says that he
will lower prescription prices watch the
follow-up if I am
elected president I'm gonna cut
prescription drug costs in this country
by 50% so that we are not paying any
more than other major countries are
paying maybe we gonna do that
because we will look at the average
costs of prescription drugs in Canada UK
Germany Japan and France but we will
look at their average costs which are
50% lower than they are in the United
States and we will do that and then she
says so your Medicare for all plan is
popular okay you looking at average cost
doesn't actually make the costs go down
but she doesn't ask okay so how will
that accomplish anything how are you
looking at the average cost of drugs in
France and Canada make the drug prices
in the United States go down she doesn't
ask that question instead she just goes
so Medicare for all really popular huh
very convenient to be a Democrat the
radicalism of the Democrats was on full
display over the weekend we'll get to a
little bit more of that we will also get
to the crisis on our southern border
where legitimately thousands and
thousands of people are arriving we just
don't have the facilities to handle all
of them first
let's talk about those hideous window
treatments that you've got I'm talking
about
the blinds in your home let's be honest
taking the time to pick out and buy
blinds it sounds expensive kind of
boring installing them yourself sounds
harder than any self-respecting adult
wants to admit but blinds calm makes it
really easy for you you're not sure what
you want or even where to start with
blinds calm you get a free online design
consultation you just send them pictures
of your house and they send back custom
recommendations for a professional for
what will work with your color scheme
furniture and specific rooms they will
even send you free samples to make sure
everything looks as good in person as it
does online every order gets free
shipping and here's the best part if you
accidentally miss measure or pick the
wrong color if you make a mistake
blinds.com will remake your blinds for
free they've made it easy for you so
there's no excuse to leave up those
mangled blinds that make your place look
like a set from the wire for a limited
time get 20% off everything at blinds
comm when you use promo code Ben that is
blinds.com promo code Ben for 20% off
everything for wood blinds cellular
shades roller shades and more blinds.com
promo code Ben rules and restrictions do
apply I've used blinds.com myself it is
super convenient super easy and they are
extraordinarily effective all of their
services are great go check them out
right now at blinds.com use promo code
Ben to get 20% off everything okay in
just a second or
get to the rest of the Democrats plus
the crisis on the southern border and
it's April Fool's that means we have to
let the left to teach us biology for a
minute but first you're gonna have to go
over to daily we're calm and for $9.99 a
month you can subscribe to daily wire
comm that means you get the rest of this
show live it means the rest of my show
later today live we got two more
additional hours that come to you every
single day and you get a commercial free
on demand when you are a subscriber
that's a lot of material when you get
the annual subscription you get this the
very greatest in beverage vessels
leftist years
hot or cold tumbler go take a look at it
right now it's unreal it's so good also
make sure that you go pick up a new copy
of my new book the right side of history
the number one New York Times bestseller
it continues to soar on the bestseller
charts go check that out right now I
think that you will really enjoy it I
think it's a meaningful book all about
sort of what Western civilization is and
the route in which it is is based go
check that out right now
there all sorts of goodies by the way
when you subscribe to beyond just my
show you also get Andrew Clavin show you
get Michael Moses show if that's
something you're interested in get Matt
Walsh's show he was on our Sunday
special and speaking of the Sunday
special when you subscribe our Sunday
special becomes the Saturday special you
can watch it a day early plus there's
additional material behind the paywall
you won't get if you simply download the
episode every week so go check out all
of those fo mentioned glories also check
us out at youtuber iTunes please
subscribe and leave us a review over
there it always helps us we're the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so as they say one of the benefits of
being a Democrat is that the media never
ask you very difficult follow-up
questions this also holds true of some
of the more intelligent Emma Craddock
candidates I'm speaking of course of the
mayor of South Bend Indiana Pete buddish
he was on MSNBC and he was asked by Joe
Scarborough about his position on
abortion no serious follow-up question
for a guy taking the most extreme
abortion position you can take do you
support the late term abortion
legislation that was passed in the New
York state legislature as well as in
Virginia I don't think we need more
restrictions right now I just believe
that when a woman is in that situation
and when we're talking about some of
those situations covered by that law
extremely difficult painful often
medically serious situations where life
or health of the mother is at stake the
involvement of a male government
official like me is not healthy okay how
about when people are just killing
people on the street is the involvement
of a male public official like you
viable and useful it turns out that in
South Bend by the way the murder rate
went up in 2016 and 2017 according to
stats so there's that but in any case
the fact that there's no follow-up like
what does that have to do with anything
what does your maleness have to do with
that why should you be able to abort a
baby at 32 weeks just because you happen
to be male that's an okay thing it's
pretty incredible
no wonder Democrats keep doubling down
in their bubble nobody ever asked them a
tough follow-up question and then of
course you have people like Beta Beta is
just a fortune cookie of a candidate
unbelievably enough he continues to ride
third in most of the major polls he
continues to be at like 12% so it goes
Biden and then Bernie and then bado
so it's all a bunch of white guys at the
top whose names start with B well
actually one whose name starts with an R
but we call him beta in any case beta or
uck tweeted out the unprecedented
concentration of wealth power and
privilege in the United States must be
broken apart opportunity must be fully
shared with all we must have the
opportunity to succeed together as one
country so just to get this straight
beta O'Rourke is such a doofus that this
tweet begins with with wit we have to
destroy all of the unity in the country
and then we can do that as one country
that's the thing we need unity when we
destroy I have to pee
in the country that's really really
important we have to destroy all
concentration of wealth power and
privilege in the United States you have
to break all that apart and then once we
do that then we can be one country the
sort of revolutionary rhetoric on the
part of the left continues to be frankly
kind of frightening and I think it's one
of the reasons why President Trump
continues to pull evenly with every
Democratic candidate who has put up
against him despite the fact that he is
personally in terms of popularity not
particularly popular speaking of
President Trump the breaking news on the
border is that there is indeed a massive
crisis on the southern border because
thousands and thousands of people are
arriving at that southern border and
we've got no resources to deal with them
effectively it's really quite
frightening according to USA Today under
a bridge connecting the u.s. with Mexico
dozens of migrant families crammed into
a makeshift camp set up by US Customs
and Border Protection the families are
there because permanent processing
facilities have run out of room 700
miles east busload after busload of
weary bedraggled migrants crowd into the
Catholic Charities humanitarian respite
Center in McAllen Texas organizers there
are used to handling 200 to 300 migrants
a day lately the migrants have been
arriving at a clip of around 800 a day
overflowing the respite center and
straining city resources it's staggering
McAllen city manager Roy Rodriguez says
really we've never seen anything like
this before along the Texas border with
Mexico from El Paso to Eagle Pass to the
Rio Grande Valley masses of migrants
have been crossing the border in
unprecedented numbers overwhelming
federal holding facilities and sending
local leaders and volunteers scrambling
since EO with the relentless waves of
people Border Patrol officials were on
pace in March for more than 100,000
apprehensions and encounters with
migrants the highest monthly tally in
over a decade according to Customs and
Border Protection Commissioner Kevin
McHale inan around 90% of those crossed
the border between legal ports of entry
so the talk that all the migrants are
simply showing up at ports ports of
entry so there's no need for a while
obviously that is untrue the vast
majority of people who are crossing
between ports of entry turn themselves
into Border Patrol agents seeking asylum
they tried to apply for asylum once they
get into Border Patrol custody and then
because we don't have the resources to
actually hold everybody a huge majority
of these people are released into the
interior of the United States President
Trump of course recently declared a
national emergency at the border to
secure funding for a proposed wall
on Friday the president in a tweet
threatened to close the us-mexico border
if Mexico didn't stop undocumented
migrants from coming but it's unclear
what exactly that means when he says
he's gonna close the border
I suppose that just means that anybody
who shows up at a port of entry is going
to be turned away that we simply won't
let anybody in if people show up to
Border Patrol
what does Border Patrol going to do just
re release them back into the desert
that doesn't seem like that's an actual
policy it seems mostly like a slogan in
El Paso migrant families pressed their
faces against the chain-link fencing at
the makeshift outdoor shelter under the
Paso del Norte International Bridge as
they awaited their turn to seek asylum
children covered their mouths with
swaths of mylar blankets and peeked
through the fencing at passing Border
Patrol guards on Wednesday more than 850
migrants were released to local shelters
marking a new high for El Paso when
those numbers are expected to continue
rising a lot of this is an expectation
of a rough summer so people are trying
to get in as fast as humanly possible
before the heat of the summer kicks in
president Trump correctly tweeted out
the Democrats have given us the weakest
immigration laws anywhere in the world
Mexico has the strongest and they make
more than a hundred billion years on the
billion a year on the United States
therefore Congress must change our week
at Malaysian laws now and Mexico must
stop illegals from entering the United
States
well the truth is that we have enough
immigration laws on the books to deport
all these folks but we don't have the
resources to do it because the Democrats
refuse the resources when they talk
about the humanitarian crisis on the
border that is a crisis that they have
greatly exacerbated by not giving Border
Patrol the resources that they need a
president Trump is in the middle of an
argument with members of his own
government because he has now cut eight
El Salvador Guatemala and Honduras on
Saturday he blasted those countries he
said they were sending migrants to the
United States he threatened to shutter
the us-mexico border which presumably
would also include trade from south of
the border people say that if that were
to happen the supply of avocados in the
United States would be gone in three
essentially three weeks which means that
Millennials would finally have an excuse
to get off their butts and stop playing
video games to be upset a surge of
asylum seekers from the three countries
have sought to enter the United States
across the southern border in recent
days according to Reuters on Friday
Trump accused the nations of having set
up migrant caravans and sent the North
weirdly enough his own Secretary of
Homeland Security Christian Nils
has been suggesting the opposite that
these countries are actually trying to
help us in preventing all of this from
happening the Honduran Foreign Ministry
on Saturday called the US policies
contradictory but stressed that its
relationship with the United States was
solid close and positive Homeland
Security Secretary Christian Nielsen
says that Border Patrol officials have
been overwhelmed by a sharp increase in
asylum seekers many of them children and
families who arrived in groups fleeing
violence and economic hardship in the so
called northern triangle a border shut
down would disrupt tourism in us-mexico
trade it's not clear how shutting down
ports of entry would you turn asylum
seekers because they're legally able to
request help as soon as they set foot on
US soil so as I say more of a slogan and
then an actual policy here that said
more funding is needed and by the way
cutting aid to these countries that
would be a worthwhile cause if it
actually resulted in better governance
in those countries but I'm not sure that
that's actually the case either so this
seems mostly like President Trump being
incredibly frustrated rightly so at the
situation on the southern border and
lashing out as opposed to an actual
coherent policy Mick Mulvaney the acting
White House chief of staff is defending
president Trump's threats to end
assistance to three Central American
countries he said why are we talking
about closing the border not to try and
undo what's happening but simply to say
look we need the people from the ports
of entry to go out and patrol in the
desert where we don't actually have a
wall so I guess that this is a a selling
point that sounds like a sort of
backfilled justification to me from old
aney
the president's chief of staff Trump's
attempt to seal off the border by
building a wall according to the New
York Times and mulling the closure of
ports to tamp down on immigration and
drug smuggling is at odds with a nagging
reality a nagging reality smuggling
activity largely comes through ports of
entry according to government data I
mean that is true but it is also true
that the people are not coming through
the ports of entry he said President
Trump said I'm not playing games
Mulvaney criticized jeh Johnson who is
the head of the Department of Homeland
Security under Obama for saying in an
interview that the situation at the
border was truly in crisis he says we
hate to say we told you so we need
border security we're gonna do the best
we can with what exactly we have the
problem is there are no real good
solutions absent some sort of change in
Central and Latin America overall the
fact is that if we do
actually improve conditions in those
southern countries we are going to have
people who are seeking to flee as soon
as possible in an interview with Jake
Tapper on CNN's State of the Union
tapper pointed out to Mulvaney that
experts within the president's own
administration has said that aid money
has helped curb violence and migration
from El Salvador
Mulvaney said that that was from career
staffers he said money had not done
enough and that that does change policy
from the Trump administration's own
policy here's the reality of the
situation we have a bunch of failed
States that are south of us and those
failed States are sending people north
not because they are actively sending
people north but because failed states
emit refugees and not and these states
are at least failing that I wouldn't
call them fail but they are failing
States they are failing to limit the
violence they're failing to provide
these sort of rights that are necessary
and that has externalities the owner
they're only two ways of coping with
that helping to change the situation on
the ground in these states or to
building up our border security so much
that we can continue to deport people on
a continuing basis just like this
because if not then this crisis is going
to amount to a lot of people crossing
the border illegally and staying in the
United States with us out without us
knowing what exactly they're doing here
I'm pretty amazing all right meanwhile
the the left on April Fool's Day is
trying to play an April Fool's trick on
all of us they're telling us there is no
such thing as biological sex so you'll
recall that originally the left's
argument with regard to biological sex
of the gender and biological sex were
two separate things gender was feminine
or masculine attributes the Left
suggested that these were utterly
disconnected from actual sex which is
not true obviously there are a lot of
masculine attributes like physical
strength and certain attitudes and how
people act in many ways that are
different whether you are a physical
male or a physical female but they say
that you can define yourself as more
feminine or more masculine and you have
conscious decision making power over
some of that stuff or maybe you don't
maybe gender is just how you
quote-unquote identify but that is
something that is driven by some sort of
brain software as opposed to the
biological physical Hardware of your
being that was their original case and
it wasn't a particularly strong case it
wasn't a particularly sensible case but
at least you could make the case now the
left is doing something further now they
are attempting to say that biological
sex no longer
exists the biological sex is itself a
myth Teen Vogue has released a video in
which they have several intersex people
meaning people who are born with genetic
conditions that mean that they have
certain secondary sex characteristics of
the other sex even though they are for
example genetically male there they're
using that as an example to say that sex
doesn't exist this is nonsense
it's just silly it's silly because to
suggest that biological conditions
somehow negate basic biological
dichotomies is silly it's like saying
that if you are born with if you are
born with a spinal condition that this
means that spines do not exist not the
same thing here is Teen Vogue trying to
push that propaganda point high I'm
gonna Gabi and I'm here to tell you the
binary is both gender is about your
identity your expression and it's often
based on ideas about sex it's important
that we really break down what are we
talking about when we talk about sex and
gender and is there something called
biological sex and what does that mean
this idea that the body is either male
or female is totally wrong and I am
living proof of that
we know intersex people exist and
breakdown this binary we all have
characteristics that are typically male
and typically female and it is really
about political choices social factors
ideological choices that we assign
meaning to different parts of our body
april fools that's a bunch of crap
that's a bunch of nonsense every
mammalian species has biological
dichotomy between male and female that's
how the species procreates to pretend
that these things no longer exist
because you wish they didn't is really
really silly but unfortunately this is
becoming a more mainstream view among
people on the left and it is nonsense
for example there's a piece by a dr.
Michael Rice shirt in today's a New York
Times called it's dangerous to be a boy
and then the headline says they smoke
more fight more and are far more likely
to die young than girls but their
tendency to violence isn't innate um
yeah it is actually in fact in every
mammalian species of which we know the
male's of the species are more
aggressive and fight more because that's
what they do I mean this is true in all
of our of our animal kingdom ancestors
it is true among babies as well there
are real sex differences between males
and females the let's attempt to write
out science it's pretty astonishing
I mean it's on the order of pretending
that vaccinations don't do anything or
suggesting or suggesting that aborting a
fully grown child is in fact just a
cluster of cells I mean this is just
science denial it's basic science denial
and yet this is now being pushed by an
enormous number of people of the left
who suggest that politics ought to
override science I thought that this was
the party of science I was informed by
the secular humanists left than what
they really wanted was science not
religion
now as I argue in my new book if you
actually want science you have to make
certain religious assumptions about the
ability of human beings to discover such
a thing as objective truth not just
evolutionarily beneficial truth but
objective truth that's a religious
assumption you have to assume that human
beings are created with the capacity to
reason you have to assume then we come
to a scientific truth that it holds for
a non chaotic universe
none of that those are all faith-based
principles none of those are rooted in
pure science they're assumptions that
you have to make but the left which has
thrown out those assumptions is then
surprised when science caves in on
itself and that's what you are watching
in astonishing manner with mainstream
outlets pushing absolute scientific
nonsense like there's no such thing as a
boy and there's no such thing as a girl
because I don't want there to be a boy
and I don't want there to be a girl
totally crazy stuff ok time for it some
things I like and then some things that
I hate so things that I like today full
points to Chris Rock so the
n-double-a-cp Image Awards happened over
the weekend and those Image Awards one
of the nominees was justice Millette
you know the race crime hoaxer and there
was apparently some sort of moratorium
that had been declared on making jussie
Smollett jokes at the n-double-a-cp
then they unleash Chris Rock on the
stage of the n-double a-c-p and Chris
Rock wasn't having any of that no jussie
Smollett jokes
yeah I know I know what a waste of light
skin you know you know what I can do
with that light skin that curly hair my
Kerela beat oh yeah run in Hollywood
that's no no no just what the hell was
he thinking from now on I never won't
know just you Jessie from now on
hey see so Chris Rock taking it straight
to the n-double-a-cp bosses over there
who suggested that he was not supposed
to make those sorts of jokes good for
Chris Rock okay other things that I like
so over the weekend I have to be say
over the past few nights I've watched a
lot of movies why because I have to sign
a lot of books for folks I mean I have
like thousands and thousands of book
plates I'm supposed to sign and so that
means it's time to watch TV and sign
books well there's a new movie out at
Netflix with Kevin Costner and Woody
Harrelson called the Highwaymen about
the police officers that exit former
Texas Rangers who took down Bonnie and
Clyde this movie is latent ly so
right-wing it's it's really astonishing
here is a little bit of the preview for
the highwayman but you got in here 16 I
think it might be good to have a doctor
look at you sometime might be good to
have doctor with you sometime ain't got
no Burton
because I was covered you may have heard
there was prison break
it was Bonnie and Clyde governor this
has to end so the movie is really good
and it's not at all about Bonnie and
Clyde it demonstrates what sociopaths
they were I mean they legitimately
killed normal people the the myth of
Bonnie and Clyde that was pervade by
Warren Beatty and Faye Dunaway that they
were sort of just dispossessed
misunderstood young people no they were
actual criminals who were robbing like
gas station attendants and killing
people who are innocent it wasn't just
them killing police officers bad enough
and so the movies about the law tracking
them down there are some moments in it
that are pretty pretty great go check it
out the Highwaymen with Kevin Costner
and and Woody Harrelson Harrelson is
really terrific I didn't used to like
what he Harrelson very much as an actor
and he's really grown on me he's really
good in this okay time for a couple of
things that I hate ok so there's a new
movie that is out is called unplanned
and I have seen it it is very effective
there's one scene right near the
beginning that is incredibly effective
where they actually show what a what a
an abortion looks like it looks like
maybe a tenth or eleventh week abortion
and it is deeply unpleasant but that is
the whole point of it now I think that
it is really important for people to
know what the hell they're talking about
when they talk about abortion I've said
for years that the use of euphemistic
language with regard to abortion as
though it as an anodyne clean nothing of
a procedure is just nonsense it is not
true it is the killing of a human being
and in the killing of an incipient human
life and this movie makes no bones about
it well unplan has been dominating at
the box office I mean he did really well
it battles 26.1 million dollars over the
weekend which is amazing this is pure
flix is the anti abortion feature it
wasn't a huge win by major studio
standards but the for the indie label
which produced the 5 to 6 million budget
it's an achievement because the
controversy the the picture has
weathered a lot of controversy we talked
about it on our radio show actually one
of the stars of the film it was rated R
by the MPAA which is amazing because as
Matt Walsh points out if they were just
showing a picture of a gallbladder
surgery and the clean
the gallbladder that wouldn't been
rated-r but everybody knows that an
abortion is in a violent procedure and
so it was rated R that is why this
happened it's a it's an effective movie
because it does show those sorts of
things
twitter apparently banned them
supposedly accidentally unplanned this
is why this is the thing i hate and then
people are trying to follow them and
getting automatically unfollowed follow
again automatically unfollow because
Twitter's algorithm is all screwed up
the reason supposedly that Twitter had
banned all of this is because they had
frozen their account because they'd been
rated R or something it doesn't make any
sense they've apologized for it still
it's bad stuff unplanned is doing
serious business bring your pro-choice
friends to see it if you can go check it
out right now and apparently the the
pure flix CEO Michael Scott he said we
are very happy for the success of the
film to bring the story of Abby Johnson
who's a former plant Planned Parenthood
clinic director to audiences and have
them show up in such large numbers shows
how the topic of abortion is so
important to bring to audiences we hope
that those on both sides of the debate
will see unplanned I'm gonna be hard to
get folks on the left to see it if you
can you should because it is an
important film it's an it has an A+
rating at cinema score right now and
despite being an r-rated film it
distributed just behind God's not dead
as far as pure flicks is big-budget
films the trailer it has about 1.7
million views you should go check it out
I'm sure we'll be talking more about it
in the very near future ok we will be
back here a little bit later today with
two additional hours of programming
which is why you should subscribe the
meantime go pick up my book the right
side of history which continues to top
the bestseller charts it will either see
you here this afternoon or we'll see you
here tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua ov era
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wired
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey everyone its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show Donald Trump says
America will never be socialist we were
born free and will stay free the left
says not so fast who's got the right of
it
we'll talk about it on the Andrew Clavin
show I'm Andrew Clavin